any has anarchic felt like starting a
completely new job with a completely new
character you know waking up in this
kind of frenetic fractious angry
emotional lost you know place and you
know trying to piece slowly piece your
life back together and kind of I
approached it like honestly like I was
the hero of the story because I think
you know it's a much more interesting
way to approach you know someone who
people will consider a bad guy in a
villain to justify every action that you
take it's kind of your responsibility
when you're playing a character like
that so so I felt like I have a little
bit of free rein and what would this
sort of brain injuries and and
everything I felt like I had quite free
rein to be emotionally very volatile and
so so that was really exciting for me to
to read about oh you know in this scene
he throws a chair and I was like well
what if he doesn't throw a chair and he
just curls up in the corner and cries
and then in the scene where he's crying
because I'm gonna cries what if I smash
something right you know just just just
to keep it feeling really like like on
the edge all the time I was wondering
that if you felt like you were
essentially playing two different
characters from last season to this I
did and then the interesting thing is to
try to so in who he really is and the
theme of like do do we despite being
changing our circumstances completely
and even our you know even your memory
and there in your perception of who you
are will you will you inevitably slide
back into a place of where your faults
are brewed from you know because of his
histories of will he essentially always
end up this sort of narcissistic guy who
is out only for him for himself and for
and to put himself on them
you know at the top or is there any
salvation for him right and you spent a
lot of time behind that mask was there a
lot of challenge with the physicality of
kind of performing with the mask on I
found it really freeing yeah as soon as
I saw the mask for the first time we
went back into makeup and I said you
have to shave my head cuz I need you
know just to give it that institutional
feeling but just to kind of free me from
any kind of concern because the first
season is so
narcissistic and concern with the
Burberry and that winds are not of the
tire and the hair gel and the
moisturizer and I wanted to do the exact
you know as much the opposite of that as
I can and just like buying slate really
and literally the blank slate of the
white mask at the beginning but it's
very freeing because you feel like oh no
one's watching me no one can see me so
so I can feel free to react however
isn't is instinct and it's really
interesting to act opposite that as well
because you're getting the movement of
been you know in the first few scenes it
was kind of it's you have to change you
just change your own reaction to what's
happening there was a lot of I think
because then you can't see the facial
reactions and it's the movement and the
interpretation of that yeah but
extrapolating what you were saying you
were saying before about um about you
know this is this is a this is a show
where you have to work a little bit
harder there's a challenge to like
figure out what's happening with these
characters in their minds it's not just
you're supporting the bad guy to kick
though to supporting the good guy to
keep the bad guy and win the girls not
that simple
these characters have been through a lot
they've all been through traumas good
and bad and so to try and figure out
what's going on with them so that mask
is like an extension of that like what
is what is going on behind this facade
it was it was cool to watch there was a
lot of times where I was just in there
like he's good
and we're we picking things back up with
Madani last time we saw her she was very
injured how does this impact her this
season and what is she facing this
season well I think her journey is you
know it's almost opposite to what been
had with filly in that she's very much
still stuck in that horror what had
happened to her in season one the whole
yeah yeah and she hadn't him you know
she hadn't let anyone in for a long time
when she kind of started to trust me so
and then when he betrayed her it was
kind of like that was the last war so
when we see her this season she's
fixated on revenge and she'll do
anything together and we see a really
interesting kind of toying with the idea
okay morally what's right and wrong and
the end she makes a decision
and then there's a big bang
[Music]